jared is with us in los angeles hi jared
how are you
i'm good mr ramsay how you doing better
than i deserve what's up
hey i was calling cause uh sadly my wife
and i found you guys a little too late
but in december of 2020 we got into a
fleece
and we want to get out of that and
currently we are on
baby step number two but the problem is
we have
we put all of our savings and
got down to the thousand dollars of
emergency fund towards our debt to pay
off credit card and one debt
so now we have at least that now i see
that we should get out of immediately
yeah we don't know the next steps we
should take um
okay well we've got to gather up some
numbers to ascertain the damage
yes sir all right um the first number is
you call the fleece company and you ask
them what the early buyout
is which is effectively your payoff for
today have you already done that
yes sir it is uh 38
740. okay and so this is a long
term fleece isn't it how was it a five
year
uh it's only a three year a three year
okay
38 000. have you looked up the value of
the car yet
yes uh it's because it's a 2021
kbb actually doesn't even have it can't
even give you the value so i looked at a
2021
2020. it's a honda odyssey the 2020
if i trade it in it's 34 000 if i go
private party
the range is 36 to 38. okay
so yeah um hypothetically if you could
sell to an individual then you could
probably get out of it whole right
because if you can sell it for 38 and
you can give the fleece company 38
and they give the title to you then
you've got your deal and you're out
right yes and that's that's the that's
the goal here
um that may be tough for two reasons
one is it's freaking brand new and two
is if somebody's gonna buy a brand new
car they're gonna buy a brand new car
uh and uh two is it's a very expensive
car because it's you know forty thousand
bucks
and not a lot of people walking around
forty thousand bucks in their pocket uh
buying off of craigslist uh when you get
much
when you get much up above 20 something
you start to get a little bit less
transactions private sale yeah a lot of
these trends a lot of transactions then
a dealer
of some kind involved um
okay so it sounds like you probably get
a dealer to pick it up for like
34 36 maybe right yes
leave you a couple grand in the hole
what's your household income
uh 138 000. well that's good news yeah
okay
well the only thing i would know to do
is to stop the um
stop the debt snowball temporarily and
pile up the cash to get
out to get this transaction done and
then you've got to figure out a way to
get the car
sold to someone for somewhere in that 36
range hopefully and you put
you know you're going to need another
car obviously and so
if we budget five seven thousand or
whatever for a car
and we need three for this you need 10
grand to do this it's going to take you
a couple months to gather that up right
yes i have uh the problem is we we got a
van which our
already was humbling you know but we
have three kids in part
i mean you bought the bentley of vans
the honda odyssey i mean yeah
yeah i know i know it's so funny it's a
fabulous car i mean
rachel cruz will sell you one she likes
hers she can she could be a honda
salesman i'm telling you
is that what she got it was honda
honestly wasn't it uh in the video yeah
that was odd odyssey
yeah sharon rachel's is yeah yeah okay i
thought it was i thought it was you know
so anyway yeah she thinks it's the best
car since sliced bread but yeah i
actually love it now
it just took me a while to relax yeah i
mean it's that it's that whole thing you
move into the van
stage of life yeah that's a tough move
some midlife crisis looking for a place
to happen
but uh yeah so anyway aside from that
yeah you've got to figure out a way to
replace this thing now how much debt do
you have other than this
so outside of the lease we have 95 000.
what is that student loans no it's
uh we got solar panels on our house
as as well as a heloc okay okay and he
locks more
less than half your annual income right
yes
okay yeah so you we're looking at a
hundred and
uh thirty thousand bucks and you make a
hundred and thirty
and so if you could be debt-free in two
years and keep the car that might be a
possibility too
just keep paying the fleece until you're
debt-free and then once you're debt-free
pay the fleece off early
buy it on out for yourself and keep it
if your wife loves the car and you
are thinking the van is cool now yeah i
mean you you could treat you treat it
like a car debt
i wouldn't have signed you up for this
thing okay for a lot of reasons
but uh uh but but you're there now and
getting out of it's gonna cost you 10
grand out of pocket
in in a replacement car minimum a little
seven thousand dollar van of some kind
um and you've got this really high
income so what kind of trajectory is
your income on is it going to shoot up
from here
yes it's still i'm supposed to get a
raise this year
we were thinking of getting out of the
lease because now i feel stupid
and getting a cheaper car um because
in the long term we don't think we want
to buy this car we rather get something
that we can hold for a long time that we
something cheaper but we wanted to see
your opinion
i i'm fine i'm getting out of it i was
trying to i'm trying to figure out a way
if it is there a scenario in which you
keep the thing is what i was trying to
figure out but now that you're there
but uh but if you want out of it that's
how you get out of it you got to pay the
difference
in what somebody will give you in 38
yes and then you've got to also have on
top of that money to get something to
drive
yeah so what are you driving i
have a paid off uh toyota camry
how many kids do you have we have three
kids
five three one okay so you're into
another used van of some kind right
an suv or something right yes okay
all right well you can do this um
but you're gonna have to buy a nice
enough van that it becomes that's as
nice as your car
that it becomes it becomes her car
because the federal law is mama gets a
good car
i was just about to say that that's what
i want i want her to get the good time
yeah so that you know it's a ten
thousand dollar move here
yeah okay so how quick can you stretch
together 10k
if you stop everything if i stop
everything uh
that's what we're trying to figure out i
figured we learned that i eat too much
so i gotta stop that
well that that's not really not a
financial thing
i eat too much out i should say eat
something
me too chocolate doughnuts but what's
that got to do with money okay
now you're getting perfect i think 10
000 um
we can get done in six months to eight
minutes no i think you can do it in
three yeah i was about to say man you
make 130 right
how much is this fleece payment the
police payment is 5.85
that's not as bad as i thought i was
going to get seven okay good
all right good okay yeah i mean
tighten that budget up and let because
the quicker you get this thing done the
faster you can get started on your debt
snowball without the 500 coming out
the faster you're going to be out of
debt and so i i
you know if you're ever going to turn up
the heat to white hot intensity
you know blue flame level baby it would
be to get rid of the van
yeah because the fat and the by the way
the faster you get rid of it the
the the more it's going to bring i mean
if you wait six months this car is not
going to bring anywhere near what it'll
bring today
right yeah so we need to get out of this
thing
pronto yeah as a matter of fact if you
have the ability to borrow the 10 000 i
probably would do it and just get it
done
because you're going from 38 000 down to
10.
yeah yeah i would go ahead and do that
if you can find a deal where you do a
trade-in and walk out with a usable
seven thousand dollar van and you eat
the three
and so you have a ten thousand dollar
loan and that car dealer sets you up
with a little car loan
i'd do that deal because that's moving
down in debt
yeah yeah cause we're gonna go down
obviously in a lot of cars
uh a bunch but you're going from but
you're going
you know you're cutting your debt by 75
percent on this
from 40 to 10 10
i think i did that math right yeah close
enough
30 grand yeah you right there